frayeur et panique pour les résidants du
sud de la californie secoué vendredi
soir par un tremblement de terre d'une
magnitude de 7,1 sur l'échelle de
richter
plus fort encore que le précédent séisme
qui a frappé la région deux jours plus
tôt quand la secousse a frappé tout est
tombé par terre ça ressemblait à une
scène de film et sa conjointe craignais
pour son bébé de sept mois
le chef de la police a mis en garde la
population contre une récidive
la communauté de reach crest compte 29
mille habitants leur est venu dit-il
préparez vos à ressentir encore des
secousses pour les deux prochaines
semaines
ça ne s'arrêtera pas de sitôt l'état
d'urgence a été décrété dans deux comtés
du sud de la californie
les secousses ont été ressenties jusqu'à
los angeles et las vegas
leur épicentre était heureusement situé
dans une zone peu peuplée faisant des
dégâts matériels
déclenchant un incendie et une scène de
panique chez ses animateurs une
télévision locale
cette seconde secousse dix fois plus
dévastatrice que celle de jeudi fait
planer le spectre du big one un séisme
de magnitude 8 qui pourrait rentrer la
faille de san andreas
les évènements des derniers jo ne sont
pas localisés sur la faille de san
andreas est dans ce sens et n'augmente
pour la probabilité d'avoir un le big
one notamment de façon imminente
c'est deux régions bien différent depuis
jeudi une vingtaine de séismes de faible
magnitude et au moins 1200 répliques
d'intensité variés ont été ressenties
dans la région
ici à smoke rails at radio canada
montréal